and we are also getting ready to say  goodbye to 2020 and welcome 2021 here on  channel 8.  for three decades we have been counting  down the new year and this year we will  once again take you through  every time zone starting with the ball  drop in times square in new york  we'll be live from stadium swim inside  circa it's incredible  we'll have performances from zoe bowie  and much more and we want everyone to  have a safe new year we will be social  distancing  and will all have been covered screened  during what has been a trying year for  so many  will be raising money for food banks  across the country  with the super bowl of caring our goal  is to hit one  million meals we hope you stay home stay  safe  and join us at 8 59 our time  to be specific